so i get that you say look guys we're
going to tackle real problems like
healthcare and education
that are thorny and human and difficult
and might not have the the same kind of
trajectory as like the
um the business or consumer facing tech
that we're used to
and then i get that your investors are
like wait a minute i didn't sign on for
this stuff
necessarily but you know come on jamal
you could like
pick all these winners in like easier
spaces uh and then eventually you're
like hey guys like
that's not really what i'm about um so
i'm curious how many other folks
have the same mindset you do where it's
like look i made a lot of money
i want to handle i want to tackle really
important problems
that aren't as market friendly or time
frame friendly
as the stuff we customarily invest in um
there's a handful of folks
um i think that um the the the sort of
the
the grandfather of the space the person
who's really
pioneered this path is a guy by the name
of vinod khosla
um yeah he's a he's an incredible
entrepreneur and his firm coastal
ventures i think has done
um huge amounts to help the world in
climate change and sustainability and
agriculture
he's an example i think that there are
other organizations actually now that
are more institutional that focus on
innovation lux capital as an example
based in new york
so there are some but by and large
the incentives aren't to do that the
incentives are that you can get
paid a lot of money to just basically
you know put money into things that are
obvious
mark up those companies raise another
fund and
rinse and repeat because that pays you a
great yearly compensation
and at that point you know that's you
you kind of have to ask yourself
why would i even bother trying to solve
cancer you know like this is crazy it's
just going to take too long too much
money i may look stupid i may get fired
and so um you know people's own
simplified incentives kick in
um and innovation stops yeah it's much
easier to try and
jam yourself into airbnb or uh pre-ipo
or something and then like turn around
and be like hey
like i'm a genius investor i had my
annual meeting today
and what was so funny is i remember um
this is for my historic venture funds
you know and look i
put a billion three or four into the
ground and
you know i told these guys look guys
you're gonna make somewhere between five
and six billion dollars
so congratulations it's all great and
one of my
ex partners texted me he said you know
these are the same guys who just got so
agitated when you did a 3d
you know rocket printing company which
is now the second most valuable space
business after uh spacex that's private
you know where we did this uh satellite
business that's also a multi-billion
dollar business where we did
uh an ai chip company that's helping to
you know do a lot of interesting things
in science
um you were just not rewarded and again
i go back to this peter teal discussion
if peter hadn't forced me
or hadn't put peer pressure on me to put
so much money in i would have never made
those investments
now the way that i think about it is
look you know
i have a pretty
like crazy track record and just kind of
making
money which is kind of okay um it's
nothing that i'm particularly proud of
but i want to use it and so the way i
think about it is
you know we have an organization where
if you put money in a ton of money comes
out we've done it for 10 years it's and
it's like 35
to a year return so when you put you
know five or 10 billion dollars into a
system like that every year you're
spitting out two or three or four
billion of cash
but then i can take that andrew and i
can pump it into climate change and i
can pump it into education
and you know because it's all of our own
capital all of my own capital
um i don't have to answer to anybody
except the employees and the founders
and the market right and so you know for
example there was a really incredible
innovation that came out a few weeks ago
from google called
um alpha fold now what is that they're
using machines
to guess the structure of proteins and
you may think well what does that have
to do with me
well as it turns out that is the basic
building block
to eradicate and solve an enormous swath
of diseases
and so we have reduced an incredible
problem of human health
to one of compute power and to one of
distribution
now that's where i could easily pour a
billion dollars of capital
spend the next 10 years and say guys
let's take you know
crawl walk run an approach and let's
just have 20 or 30 really important
diseases that we can
you know basically put out a business um
and i don't have to answer to anybody
except the scientists that work on the
projects and then the market and the
people suffering from those diseases
will say chemoth
faster or hey it doesn't work or hey it
looks like it's working
um and so i find myself for the first
time
very happy actually like you know
reasonably content because
we have this you know it's kind of like
being a country andrew i think in like
you know like you're saudi arabia and
one day you wake
up and it's like there's oil underneath
your feet
and all you have to do is just suck it
out and then when you sell it in the
market you have money except in our case
we have a plan with what to do with the
money
you know we we have these areas that we
just think need to get fixed
for humanity just to thrive that's
incredible that
you've gotten that kind of visibility
into some of the thorniest problems and
you feel like you can make headway in
solving them i spent a number of years
running a non-profit that was trying to
help
young entrepreneurs in different markets
around the country primarily in the
midwest and the south i would interact
with
billionaires um and then i would say hey
support my non-profit or support this
thing i'm doing
and if they were into it they would make
a move
but even if you are a billionaire you
don't move in increments of like
you know 25 30 million like if if they
were
wanted to be really supportive of my
organization i might get one or two
million
um and then i would be you know frankly
i have to be like well that's freaking
awesome because you know two million
dollars it's like nothing to sneeze at
um but but there was this sense i had
that among these billionaires i knew
like they were looking at trying to
solve particular problems and they
didn't think they had the resources
and you're like wow i'm like with a
billionaire and like they don't think
they have it
um so i'm curious what your mindset has
been when you look at some of like the
biggest
problems humanity is facing uh and
the scope of the problem relative to the
resources that are being applied to
solve that problem
i i really haven't met a problem that is
really
one of capital um and i think that i
have more than enough resources to solve
all the problems that we're trying to
solve except one critical one
which is human capital and i think
that's the
that's the most important thing to take
away which is that it's not that for
example like
let's just say that you and i said hey
let's go and get every single home in
america to be carbon neutral
okay that's at a great goal right how
would we do it well i can tell you i can
tell you what the answer is and the
answer is actually not
too complicated which is every house has
a roof
every roof can support residential solar
all of that solar energy can get
basically stored on site in an extremely
safe
and predictable battery and then you can
give
the homeowner or the apartment dweller
an app
that allows you to know exactly how much
energy those solar cells on the roof has
has generated and then you can use it to
power the home or the apartment
and whatever is less you can put back
into the grid so
how do you solve it as it turns out it's
not one of capital because you can get
hundreds of billions of dollars of
project finance to do that
because people spend hundreds of
billions of dollars buying the bonds of
utilities
every single day in the the marketplace
part is
can you get 15 or 20 engineers to build
the right app
that allows you to basically understand
how energy is managed and recirculated
can you get the right you know battery
scientists and chemists to build the
right battery storage technology can you
string those batteries together
across a neighborhood so what i've
found and i could be totally wrong but
what i found is that
most of these solutions are ones of
human capital
and that it doesn't take tens or
hundreds of billions of dollars people
find
ways of spending that much money but
that's just a lot of um
poor planning now if eventually andrew
you and i were to find a solution
what i would say is it probably would
cost 50 million to figure out
then you and i would say let's go to a
small town like palo alto or
you know some place and say let's deploy
that there and figure it out
and then let's go to a city like austin
or miami and say hey guys
here's what we found let's go roll it
out through all of miami and then we
would go
nationwide and along the way the capital
markets are actually
very liquid and would give you all that
money non-dilutively so
it's not that i intend to never work
with the capital markets i just think
that
in that early phase the single hardest
thing to find is actually the people
um and at the end of the day these
solutions can be found for hundreds of
millions of dollars
this is why i always sort of get trapped
in
you know people people have approached
me constantly and it's like
hey what's your philanthropic strategy
or charitable strategy and i
and i say to be honest with you i think
that
all of these problems that i'm looking
at will be solved
with technology-oriented solutions the
ones that i am the most
um sympathetic to climate change
sustainability agriculture health
education um and so you know
eventually will i you know find a way to
give all the money away sure
but right now you know i think it's
important to recycle it back into
for-profit businesses because
this is how i solve the human capital
problem the single biggest thing that
america has right now
going against it is that we have four or
five companies
facebook apple amazon microsoft google
that
sucks up the enormity and the
overwhelming majority
of all talented technical human capital
because if you are a smart young kid
you know a guy or girl graduating from a
college and you know how to code or you
know how
you know how to do something unique how
do you
turn around to your family and say i'm
going to go
and work at this startup for 80 grand a
year or this non-profit or something
else
versus going and getting paid a million
dollars a year at one of these big
companies it's really impossible right
i mean i don't know your situation but
when i graduated
that was the biggest sort of damocles
over my neck was the student debt that i
had
and so but when they go there what
products are they working on this is
unfettered free agentism imagine that
you had a professional sports league
where there was no salary cap
what would you do you would go and hire
and you would sign every single great
player stick them on the bench
you'd be guaranteed to win a
championship you'd be a monopolistic
championship winner year in europe
you're saying that they get paid to do
nothing
because when you say the bench that's
what i thought of yeah no no that's
that's
that is that is the exact explicit
strategy
absolutely so so this is why i think
again we have to find
market-driven solutions we have to find
a way to use technology to build
successful
for-profit companies because we have to
convince all these people that are
frankly withering and dying on the vine
at these companies that they should be
working at these young dynamic
businesses
you know this is the forward bleeding
edge like if you think about what
happened in
1969 right the apollo project was
the pinnacle of innovation in america
but what did you really have in that
moment what you had was an
extremely diverse ecosystem where you
had a public private partnership
you had the government that was
basically an enormous balance sheet
plus a lot of regulatory freedom and the
ability to explore
which then saw the germination of
hundreds of companies and an ecosystem
trying to get america into space and
meant to the moon and then back now we
have the exact opposite
we have the federal government that
isn't exactly sure what its posture
should be
they work with an incredibly dated set
of laws from antitrust to otherwise
section 230 and otherwise and then we
have a handful of companies
that are effectively monopolies that
understand that their balance sheet is a
tool
that their balance sheet is equivalent
to most other governments in the world
except maybe the united states right if
you if you put the gdp of countries on a
list and then put the market cap of
these big companies together these five
companies are probably
top 50 countries sure right and so
and so yeah you can green mail people
you can basically work on
all kinds of non-some you know nonsense
and random stuff and
as a result innovation slows down
um progress slows down
as a result wage growth slows down as a
result
people's frustrations grow and then they
point to capitalism
except really again what it is is a
bunch of financialization on one side
and green mail and hostage taking on the
other that have basically trapped a
whole cohort of young people and working
on the things that really matter
jamatha i spent a number of years trying
to counteract this i don't know how much
you know about my work with venture for
america
so what what uh we did was we recruited
enterprising young people some of them
technical some of them not
to work at early stage growth companies
in detroit new orleans baltimore
cleveland
birmingham and another half dozen
cities around the country that are not
new york san francisco
with the thought process being exactly
what you described which is look right
now if you're
a whiz kid out of a lot of places um
banks and consulting firms and tech
companies will wave money at you
and then you will go there and you will
do something that's not super
uh socially productive uh and so
wouldn't you rather
start a business in a place or help a
business grow in a place that
could use the talent could use the
energy could use the help i spent
six and a half years running a
non-profit that did this and has done
this
for at this point hundreds maybe
thousands of young people and i saw the
market forces you're describing in
action
where if you're a really bright
kid out of pen and you go to a startup
in new orleans and then you see your
friends getting paid six figures if it's
a bank maybe more if it's
you know certain certain tech firms and
you look up you're like oh my gosh like
what's going on
am i missing out because i'm here in new
orleans working for you know a certain
amount of money it's a very difficult
landscape
um you know venture for america had a
degree of
uh of success but also i realized the
enormity of the problem there was a
tweet during the middle of the pandemic
where some guy was like
um he was an employee at google and then
had pretended to quit and got a job at
facebook and then was being paid by both
and because they're working from home
valley episode
it's like it's like out of silicon
valley or office space and you think
this is an absolute [ __ ] joke
and meanwhile you know the earth is
burning to the ground
you know you know we can't we can't even
figure out how to like
uh do anything except distribute
burritos by cars
to people i mean it's kind of crazy
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode